the greatest coach in the history of
professional sports Sir Alex Ferguson
are you
you're looking very dapper tonight yeah
thank you
yeah my mother looks after me well ah
looks like we're the only two who got
dressed this evening huh so what would
you do sir aleksef um some of this
scruffy mob here showed up and what
players and wanted to get on the
Manchester United bus well whenever the
first I was a coach everyone had to have
a short haircut all shaven
I don't know banjo solo prison the bus
fare build that's not for me know
whether I've have I'm not what's my
strength hurdle oh that but what I did
wait to see with my team coming to a
ground the United Way's are on wait shop
and the tie because they're representing
my anticipated and what would you do if
they didn't show up like that well I
think it should as part of the education
you have to give them the responsibility
they have is a Manchester LeTip wear and
it's a sister discipline and I think
that that was a strong discipline United
and it still today even we vanghoul all
smart I know it said the boys are not
playing set in the back of the directors
box boys and finals on away that mmm-hmm
that's for me mmm-hmm I'm sorry you guys
with the beards you recommend a shave
would you so uh do you see the game on
Saturday the Everton game yeah yeah what
do you think Chloe did really well I
thought it was going to be a difficult
game actually Nassau dev attended all
the strongest team oh you know and I
thought this is gonna be a difficult
game because the West
I think we've watched the last three
years there and but they weren't very
comfortably they're complete control and
the way that changed the system a little
bit United near I thought Evan couldn't
handle it so I was pleased because after
they
great test of any women Chester dated
team is how you recover after defeat
there was three level to Arsenal a bad
defeat the commander next game when
that's the best way to to answer the
critics and also to to show the resolve
and the determination to go over a
defeat because it's no easier
coordinated because when you lose your
front page when you win your back page
it's a difference that would be on the
back page so and there are I think if I
counted correctly there were eight of
the eighteen players who showed up on
who played on or in the squad on
Saturday were players that you had
signed how how long does it take to knit
everybody else together into a really
cohesive unit is that a matter of years
or can you do it in a season well if you
talk about the present court of players
wave and gal blow and five new players
last season five you players this year
that's there we go
potato wait the players they brought in
were players from other countries the
private division is very difficult
really difficult when we brought players
in from abroad we always give them ear
first season forget it second season ok
but wanted to excelled surprises by
doing real well beginning in my time the
the thing that is different from me and
William vanghoul of course is that
adwong evety I was here 27 years so when
I went to United at first my job is to
build the foundation a football club
because I think most managers quite
rarely have to think of a football team
the first team because as a result
industry they're there to make sure the
first team does well and never thought
that way I thought were rebuilding the
the youth in the collaborate so that
gave me a foundation and give me a paper
mouth young players coming through and
Mac conviction was never going to change
at all the directors on day one
that's his hour was going to do and of
course he I was concerned over the first
in row second bottom the week and I just
to my team with that
Hoddy most concentration was on scouting
trailing and coaching the young people
now at the end of the evident game
United are in third position in the pram
in their in the English Premier League
it's the end of October and obviously
everybody here is connected to the
business school in one way or another
and an important thing in businesses
setting expectations and how would you
were you managing unite today knowing
that there's a long part of the season
still to come you still got to play
Christmas you got to get your in the
other different cups and championships
how do you go about setting the
expectation of where you would want the
club to wind up at the end of the season
knowing that you're in third position
today well I think the difference you
take my job aberdeen aberdeen is a north
of Scotland cut off from the central
Bell with the main their main stream of
footballers I had to build an
expectation had to create an expectation
of the for the players
whereas United you have to live with the
expectation so every play that comes to
that club even after Saturday's game
every play on that team has to whether
the expectation so the expectation is to
win absolutely whether it's a European
couple a week up they're all after when
that's the mentality to have the main
set is winning main se not voice for
that so I never ever said to the players
will got to when you're peak I've got
you win the week I never say that every
time we press covers well I hope we win
something I was not going to get carried
away
and give them a headline but deep down
when every game that was a mentality I
never expected it was a game ever
mmm-hmm would you be talking to the
players at this juncture about the
possibility of winning the league this
year and when would you start privately
calculating whether or not you thought
you wouldn't believe this I'm going to
tell you
every every beginning of January I used
to home opponents games and predict the
point to other we're going to get
against us and it was never far wrong
never far wrong even to the boy that and
you would have to make three points up
in it and up one of our main opponents
I was pretty accurate I did this every
year mm-hm
you know so that admah win so uh so
would you say would you sit down with
each of the club's or all the whole what
is it tell me in the points that we know
by January 1st who were main challenges
are going to be and then I used to do
that was this I kept him myself I didn't
share it with anyone I was never felt
wrong that's good I was always even the
years but it was that and you did the
dangers we had in terms of challenges
mm-hmm and you were pretty accurate
about the say in January about the
number of points that United itself
would have at the end of the season yeah
yeah so let me change the topic a little
bit to two things that again are germane
to every sort of business one is
assessing and judging talent and another
is discipline so let me take you back
it's 1957 there is a young man growing
sideburns
Alec Ferguson who's turning out in his
first seasons for a club in Scotland in
Glasgow called
Queens Park how would you assess the
talent of that player
well outstanding comes to Maine but well
I probably went a few players have
played for glass of skill Scotland
school Scotland youth Scottish are
mature and the fuel Scottish team so but
I wasn't an outstanding player I was a
goal scorer in fact him at United we
used to get to the video analysis room
most mornings and this morning a
goalkeeper coach Eddie Steele says I was
just say pulling up your goal school
record this is pretty good at 179 goals
in three hundred games or something I
nice ed Bosson wiegel's as I remember
Cup goals so I said well I'll try again
right we couldn't get them couldn't find
it [ __ ] goals a little why but know I
was a goal scorer and had a great career
with her actually winning hath and I
went to Rangers at a bad time and
shelter work employed dominant that
haven't acted just when European Cup
under jocks teen and they were a
fantastic team they were difficult to be
at that time but I enjoyed that a good
career the thing about playing as with
her as your best time of your life which
relates to I would never ask him opposed
to retire to become a coach they
encouraged him to T the badges when I
went over into fuel team of people
because I was engineer was a toolmaker
until was 22 was part-time in football I
mean Bobby no I was not going back to
engineering so I took all my coaching
badges I prepared to stay in the game
everyone should do if we're going to do
something prepare whether it's through
study or the way I did to your coaching
badges and I think it's a really
important issue and how well behaved on
the field was that young player Alex
Ferguson you Guinness my son Jason had a
bad record pardon
had a bad record huh
I'm saying often times pardon he did but
I was misunderstood
do do you remember some of the incidents
about why you were sent off every one of
them yeah The Salvation is most mostly
or maybe a weight tack or something
elbowing someone's doors Angela I was
saying at that funny run stale I run
with my it was wetter so I was always
going to trouble buttons laughing here I
was always going to talk with because of
my elbows yeah the elbows yeah yeah so
let's talk about judging other talent
several decades later I'm going to pick
on two players David Beckham or pick two
players David Beckham and another one
will come to in a moment so how do you
first come across Beckham and how old
was he and what did he seem like as a
player when you first saw him well David
came to an oyster scout in London from
the same areas derivatives that was
headmaster school Malcolm fijian and the
a David on the radar but the real the
real windpipe came from Bobby Charlton
Bobby had soccer skills at a time and
David had won a placement for Bobby
soccer school in Barcelona and Barbican
biases have seen a cage in Eden
so I [ __ ] it up with the Chiefs
codices okay of course it's coming next
month just by coincidence and that was a
start it would be a woman years of age
that Tim who is a little thin boy you
know he's in no height no physique
whatsoever but it is wonderful talent
you know in terms of control of the ball
striking the ball which is really his 40
and his parents were elated fine so his
grandfather was a Tottenham fan but he
and his peers were United fans so he
used to come to the game after we got
the contact with them we invite him to
the games every table in London in fact
it was a ball boy in a West Ham gear
which
xiri of london and he it was a certainty
to come united it he trained it turn on
for a while I think it trains somewhere
else maybe fill most of our but it was
always danced in the community because
they wanted to come to United and n is
that's class of 92 weather team to win
the Youth Cup David never gain a team
until the semi-finals because it was
just a boy then within months sexual
stealth in no no confirmation in his
body whatsoever
but it did know he was it was he's a
skinny boy them and that group and it's
as the same the same desires the
seminary of them the talk about the
winds are well knowing cake schools but
the true Devils and David but where to
other players would have been great
prayers for the careers were cut but bad
bad injury Chris Kasper and Ben Thornley
they were I was standing but they all
practiced give a sense of how hard these
guys worked well the training would
start ten o'clock to twelve o'clock the
other ones they would burn afternoon
practice in overtime or with the youth
coach in terms of the general training
and for David who lived in accommodation
with mrs. Godwin with several several
boys or other boys he would go into the
school basis in a time and help the
coaches with the young kids
so his desires were strong and and also
is a practice he practice practice
practice and I think that if the advice
I give to any young kid as anyone can
play game of football anyone the
practice makes you a real football you
see Kim's in a Sunday pub games Oh what
I gave a football the real players of
the practice hair thing about and where
you take that I've never been a lunch in
Glasgow many many years ago and Garrick
player was a coca-cola golfer and they
asked him a question
why do you keep practicing from the
bunker because it was famous for girls
bonk I says well I know I'm going to be
the in the bunker at one time in the
game maybe twice in a game and I've got
to put in a hole is that's why I
practice and practice and practice
that's a great example of what you have
to do to be a software and David in all
these young lads at that same and all
the young kids a United practice well
different well known name Cristiano
Ronaldo how old was he when you first
came across 17 he was and how did he
first hit your angry as a great story
because had Carlos Queiroz assistant and
cars of course as a Portuguese and he
thought of a good idea for us to have an
association a relationship with the
Sporting Lisbon because he'd been there
as a kid
and it was from wisdom and he said and
what we're doing then was shilling
coaching and so we would send coaches
over there they would send coaches to us
and Jim Ryan who was head of youth
department of time you skeleton brother
he came by he says what was in a player
and he was playing center for youth team
a time Cristiano Ronaldo so I sister to
cowers as you know would be a good idea
of maybe a bigger relationship here and
he spoke to the president and the deal
was that we couldn't get the next year
but we could get them two years from
from then then cows left in the next
year we'd promised through the
association with them the relationship
we'd open the new stadium this is at
sporting let's pour tea yes correct
and we flew from from the states from
here to to husband and play the game and
Christian has point outside waived
against Johnny Shea and the pure souls
is good torture torture blood tell me
honest way is absolute and I've got them
going John get up again stop this is a
kind
so I give my kid managers he's got there
to the directors box and get Pierre King
and down right away at halftime so
Pierre King you condone us is we're not
we even here Peter Kenyon was the day
chief executive
you know time yeah and says well not but
we're not going to even here with her
that boy in the plane so then we got all
him after the game with the present
their husband his agent his lawyer and
the boy that's who we need to come back
with us to Manchester there was at that
acid test if it doesn't want to come you
know he didn't want to join you
he says he had worth to come by one my
mother yeah so I was great next morning
his mother his sister's brother old the
old trip came out and I said Jim I
promise you one thing you get the best
education you can possibly get here but
you want to every week and it worked him
with that you know and he was impressed
yes if you didn't expect that as his the
primary is a very difficult week and you
may play substitute something me play an
odd game you may play the weak cop which
would you have a lot of young players
and but we said but when during the
first team well if you get to a level
that's mine Chester dated I can't stop
you you pick yourself and they played
his first game it was subbing the first
game of the season his boldly came on to
halftime a crowd win Absalom Adam it was
fantastic a cottage to take the ball a
the first air that the right back of a
bowl of whacked them right in the first
minute he came all in the same half he
got misses give me the ball you know the
great players have got this courage
nothing will dawn them they're not
afraid of anything and Cristiano had
that and had when he first came to
Manchester I think he came with his
mother and his mother and yeah how
disciplined was he in his sort of daily
ritual at that point was the best
practice of level annoying
but he had these em what you call a
latin-american false you can get
arrested for saying that in the state of
California and there's a simple form
which can be advocated if the boys with
a desire and this one and Wesson chairs
and it was a dirty word Ivan his own kid
and but I mean to try and get a penalty
yeah correct and the players would agree
with them every time we could down his
screaming boys are going screaming them
back and yeah get up yeah you know that
and and I used to get a long time
the unfortunate thing for another cuz he
was such a great player the press never
a weapon alone in that station you know
because after about a year and a half it
never happened but any time he was
felled someone along the way in the
cutting us was he oh yeah he dives a bit
you know it's not true because the
speedy was going act against a faintness
all you need to do is nudge about all
betting the Barwon scores and they go
down but a he wasn't published with I
didn't did the criticism get to him at
door no no no I remember I came off of
that time peel that their season with a
really were sent off and he says it
wasn't going to come back and laugh
where to Portugal in that system we want
to come to the good real madrid it was
always his lifetime ambition to do that
and I said look you give me here and
you're going with my blessing to Real
Madrid he was fantastic but the first
game was a childhood and I sat the
directors box and there's this going
down in front of me he's up in here's
coming him so much the cussin language
and then about five it from a half team
we got the ball I beat three men cut and
had that just say to the bar the guy
never got again I was unfinished version
he was here the courage to do all that
and Cristiano today considerable
many years later now does he still have
the same sort of drive and work ethic or
I've never known anyone wake him
honestly I was at his house for dinner a
few month ago and his house is made for
the best way in the world hood over that
house that the gymnasiums probably half
a size of this well the best bit size
here is everything that is it two pills
he's got hot pill in the cold pill he's
got a nice remain this hundred sixty
degrees it was in a for ten minutes
after the game this unbelievable his and
I system system I'm going to retire at
35 soon retire at 35 you can put here 40
so I drank exasperated father when it's
no no I'm doing that and I'm working on
make sure I'm three kilograms are in my
best way the last five years what I mean
really amazing right now with all these
people with no players of incredible
caliber Beckham Ronaldo the others that
you had how do what were the tools that
you use to maintain discipline well I
think that the most important thing is
to be consistent who you are and don't
change and I never changed I didn't use
jessamine as a as a weapon against
players they they will be disciplined of
this depth of Wayne for certain reasons
may be so its end and awful it must be
here you know say the ground but I never
used it as a continual weapon against
some movie you got this point over we
move on and they always have time
eventually limited they understand who
you are that's the most important thing
because that's the essence of being a
leader you know who you consistent the
trustee you're right and this one is an
important aspect of managing rule
there's no question but that way you're
dealing with very well-paid players if
you've got a disappoint is different
with different people is as you're going
the wrong way
so my discipline is always the same for
everyone I never - did anyone any
different and what was the sort of
discipline that the players dreaded was
it the fine or the threat of being
transferred or being put in the stands
to watch a game I think every player
wants to play no Saudi no a long endured
occasion I would disappoint a player by
being understand but the other aspect of
players and his stand is because you
were scored at 24 and you have to pick
away 11 that's difficult but why I used
to do was because we're winning
experiences our player I was told 50
minutes from a kickoff and his coach got
fan or wasn't playing I was a top goal
scorer and there's no substitute time so
that was always my mind about how to
treat players if they're not playing so
it's a calm in an individual with all of
them and explain to why they weren't
playing it was very easy towards you
know as time went on because they knew
with our score of 24 there's not that
woman to win the week is a 24 - when the
week of the cups you know no question
with that and they all the important
part they do that is to trust them from
whatever team you play and make them
feel that they have contributed like the
best players in winning interacts how do
you adhere ensure that even for the the
biggest stars they all understood that
they were part of not the but part of a
team well I think the best players the
ones that way to win more most best
players will get that Eagle when it is
important to them so I enjoyed that
I enjoyed players with that confidence
and but how do you make sure that none
of them began to think that they were
bigger than United them so the messages
to prove that a base have to work as
hard as everyone else and even more than
other ones and that was the better to
always give to them the evidence is
always the football field the best
player can wet himself down by not
webbing up to the expectation he's all
in expectation and fight so I
that's going on so I I do great
what is it with that training if I have
been near such a long time of course
helps but also think that players are
come to United they come they're such a
great club they don't want to Taylor
well you miss the bus they want to be on
the bus all the time right and I think
that was really important right now how
do you let's switch the topic a little
bit and talk about compensation some of
these players are getting paid a lot a
large amount of money obviously um how
do managers cope not you because you
were among the highest compensated in
the Premier League
but there are some clubs where the
managers are paid less than their
players how do they ever have a chance
of establishing Authority in those clubs
I think in most cases I was a bit
different because I feel always feel
they're being the manager of Manchester
nature they should be high speed person
to bear what they have it is important
because the responsibility of managing
that club is huge you run their more
deals in any of them I'll get the
biggest responsibility so I felt that
should be always recognized not always
but every years by the way - a long time
to agree with me you know
but I think from other managers point of
view I think they expect that the very
top winner is going to be paid more I
have no issue at all with what players
get paid the top players you know why I
think you look at golfers official
American footballers basketball players
investors yeah yeah exactly
or use potentially wealthy old man out
there but then I've no issue with that
because they're bringing 75,000 people
in the Old Trafford yeah yeah um what
about saying goodbye to players whether
they were 16 17 18 year olds you didn't
think we're going to make it and then
let's talk about them and then I want to
talk about some of the players who done
well by you that you can say goodbye to
what about the well the most difficult
task for any manager is telling a young
kid is you're not going to make a united
when when we bring a boy to the club we
speak to the parents and Merced we
always see this film we hope your boy
plays in front of 75,000 people if not
were confirming again my career in the
game even to this day there will be
about 90 players and England Scotland
Denmark Germany all started the clears
our minds resonated and that's been
without fluid 10 10 to 15 years very
devil to tell that I did a stupid thing
was it someone as a young coach I was
feeling I was I was I was terrified to
tell young boy he was not you know going
to be good enough so at this idea bring
fight the five element five young bulls
together and I told them me when I'm
sorry crying or whatever that was that
finished even I was a I was a difficult
time was there's no easy
um and then what about some of the older
players who'd done very well by you and
then you had to break the news to them
and I wasn't that so equal had because
the unit would become a father to them
any abyss with such a family business
Manchester netted anyway that for
instance the team on 94 with
work with us for quite a few years from
random at 91 way through to the 1967
highway Denis Irwin Steve Bruce playing
Robson carry power stone and they all
did what it whitter were 90 but they
don't actually realize that again order
you know I'm the one who recognizes
because I see in the football field
movie but what I did with them
I was made sure they were given free
transfers but you know so they made the
few Bob Dennis went to rules Steve Bruce
went to Birmingham playing Robson
actually became a manager of Meadows
work and they got a power saw and back
to Miller's rhythm so we worked after to
put Paul Parker give him a free trial so
make fuel in a free transfer they've got
clubs West Brom Paul went to film so we
did well by them and recognition for the
service they give us and I think I was
important money that doesn't convince
you when the guys come here ten years it
always so I think that's the best way
you can do it they're all the only thing
you can do and it definitely wants this
would be honest with them you don't
think of what you're not going to go try
caddies guys on right these Cesar Sears
professionals would be great to you a
different topic what about again for a
lot of people setting out on lives in
management and everything what are some
of the things that you wished you had
known when you were 30 or 32 just
setting off on your lifetime of
management up in Scotland yeah I got
this at however this is a built in
equation I did think about it for well
Ned Webb is the easiest when I think
about his communication recognition
absolutely vital and when I was tough to
to I want to rule the world you know it
was a young manager Simon most players
are playing at 32 but other ever growing
engine I gave up to go into management
it wasn't the elbows that were no there
was a little polished
and I was ordering a glass feed for the
groans windows pies for the directors
room the programs the Saturday and you
know you forget to to my new job the way
and with the chairman would they go
full-time you know when I became deaf
agree and yeah I didn't realize I still
carried on to be a dead of course he can
psyche is she dead from so let's say
let's talk about the two things one how
did you learn to delegate I think at the
natural thing of it delegation but I
wasn't preparing recognize until was I
got to it maybe sixty you know now
realizes well Frank when I keep energy
I'm going to do it and then you have to
give the trust to that and do it but
that tame anyway I trusted all my stuff
anyway it was just a natural thing that
will you get energy and you've done
something for so long you know things
have a going to change
of course he's changes you and then I
delegated far better you know I doubt
delegated a lot actually after that you
know and I think of it energy and it's
in any when listen to this is very
important when you start waveguide
alienated we see it forty-three
forty-four years of age they see the
energy the Piercy then you see bones and
oyez but when you get to the sixes they
still expect to see it so I look at
myself in terms of energy that arrows
are swept because when I was a young
manager for five years no problem
when I got to that to is my 60s I needed
six or seven hours so you go to bed air
where you look at your diet better
sardine eat swallow after the game on
home you know I never a very very seldom
learners alginate so that added things I
myself over my energy because people
want to see the energy very important
aspect of it you know right and the
second aspect of that was what you just
alluded to its mirror and coming a
cropper with a owner yeah what's the
advice you give managers these days when
they call you about the relationship
that they should have with the owner of
the club that that's exactly what you're
going find away doesn't matter what you
think of them you've got to find a way
that can be a good harmony they can go
on together yet and also to agree that
the you're both going the same direction
you know I think that if even if you
find out we actually been going on with
them and they were going that way and
you're going out with stall doesn't work
so you have to find out that way of a
green where the direction of the club is
going and the job you're doing
now think about regulation communication
is really important part to that you
must recognize that people are working
for you and knowing that names sing good
more on 2:00 in the morning
I had a manager whereas if where you
couldn't say good morning to you you
walk value that could be whack a
conference could be anything be after
you have to recognize the people work
for you and every time we want to cup a
trophy every member that staff were in
that canteen the laundry kettles the
canteen staff the groundsman champey no
because see a trophy as much as the
players that became a team that did you
enjoy the celebrations yourself no no do
we know but because maybe was for me any
game or ask for me of a half an era and
I'm thinking of it tomorrow and I was
just even after 99 1999 the famous
traveler then I went to bed and after
the Robert I went to my bed to wake up
the next morning in a bad mood or
belongs
I was exhausted after the guys way when
the team again presented with a cup I
went for a walk and the Barcelona's all
these alleys and virtual corridors and
all the lesser and I'm walking through
there and more and a bumpiness friend of
mine from Aberdeen he couldn't take
either he is walking her to be manager
and we're walking through all these
hours the name is Cedars bogey coming up
and it's a guy is working for me he says
you're going to the press conference
this is what half an hour after the game
you know I can celebrate for half an
hour you know but then it was really
quick before my rate how did you avoid
complacency and getting complacent and
also disease you know every time at half
day every when a game has come up let's
come up all the time you know there's
nothing you do but when you get
completion read a few occasions there's
never one of the same correct with
United because of human beings but we
kept reminding them when I have time
you're winning complacency you know with
said disease you know you rate a cop
this is a message I give to the team the
Ryder Cup when you the British team yeah
and I said it told them I said we would
think about Modena two years before and
the 10sec since our DNA the winning ten
six America and I sent them the dinner
and probably seen each other all we only
need four half points it's a great it's
a great idea there is that right I only
form our points and the coincidence
resonated waiter and but you don't win
the first point and the win the second
point and as artwork confusion and with
a third point paddock and in
capitulation unfortunately with that
message but Europe again into the last
game 10-6 and front
fantastic
but as a disease we had a viewpoint
Everton were last week because of it
four to seven 7 minutes ago who watched
your goals and that causes a week and
the human beings but the best way is to
keep reminding them that complacency
Kiko 7 and there's no way after we can
places complacency sets and there is no
way out
up till now we had one other question
from me and then I know we have some
audience questions you had this
incredible record that's unparalleled
did you ever feel that or do you feel
that you should have one more absolutely
I do I honestly think that European Cups
was the one as my biggest regret and
then some occasion were very unlucky
some occasions will get bad decisions
against us and some occasions we didn't
play well enough and with three semi
finals we lost and the two worst weather
against Dortmund and 97 and against
Leverkusen a 2001 we should have one
whose game does that still bother you
today yeah there's I don't think you
should ever would buy it with regrets
but well yes a question at the bones of
me all the time right
so I but at all betterness about it
because football I can work in my clear
nature and we regret anything I'm a
fantastic time but the question is will
you put to me yes we should win what
European Championships our last season
when Real Madrid that red Turkish
referee
they say what do you really think of him
he sends off nanny then we all dig my
loot control the game and but we wasn't
wasn't aware that that came at two is
ten minutes to get over it and buy that
team of the score two goals and even to
one down with it we made all the chances
mm-hmm
so as a disappointment but as I see what
you know I can again together III ahead
let me welcome Nev given she has I know
a few questions from the audience and
how many people here are soccer players
in the audience usual good no bad and
NCAA soccer players Oh fantastic I'm
going to take the liberty of asking the
first question so you touched on aspects
earlier but here in the valley are
equivalent of the prize footballers or
the best engineers they're paid the most
they get poached by rival tech companies
yet most of us at the GSB are most
likely to go in as their managers for
the early days what are your top tips to
garner their respect despite the fact
that we're not tacky retain control and
ensure that no individual becomes larger
than the team or the organization well I
think I may be answered over here we'll
be doing with queers were megastars old
players with egos and our wealthy eye
hours we believe that those people are
genuinely the winners always aim that
that's why they got there in the first
place any other be occasions were the
slip of the the platform of where they
were and maybe get complacent whatever
but it's easy to remain someone's the
winner as easy to remind them and where
they hide the got there was that
expectation I think it's important to
remainder with the they represent
themselves in a big way and I think that
should always remained it of them you
know what management trait did you not
have that you wish you had and how did
you compensate for that um
language is definitely just because when
United changed when the Academy sister
currently being and we had to change the
dynamics of the club in terms of
scouting then more European players come
in from South America from France said
to his pain whatever Germany over with
one year when your particular year with
21 nationalities in the club dried
flames in Germany at school we know
that's what when you leave school and
you don't use the languages you forget
about them so when we start again I
started thinking about who can
communicate potato with the French
players and it's no easy you know it's
languages is really important I said to
my son Marco says years ago me at school
take one is this is another one language
is I'm going to do this I'm going to do
that as this take one which is no anism
you know 20 years later and it's really
important to communicate with prayers in
their own language that's why a bloke
our Skelos and Kara spoke four or five
languages fantastic because with all
these nationalities and the
communication was easy and cows would do
all that and I would do most mutterings
are French we don't wait one German
player young boy and Z as here on his
heels with how a novel no peers or when
I need to communicate with in German so
I think it's important languages I
sympathize with that I've barely
mastered English so and I'm surprised
that though there weren't more tweets
coming through for racing or wine tips
from you seeing that your track record
on that is as good as nice yeah there
isn't tips and but I I sadly in the
audience are going to to kill me but
we've only we've only got two minutes
left so I'm going to ask a question
which to you both actually which is
somewhat synonymous with the GSB because
it's one that we will have to answer as
part of our applications and that is
what matters most and why that's a good
question
but I I think I think you're lovely and
I think Moblin was fantastic at pence
who give me a good disciplines good
advice don't be late don't cheat don't
steal don't why these things stood him
but by me or my wife and I hope then
that foundation I blinked a moment oh
dear kids and they can bring it to their
kids and that's what I don't bring in
there's an inheritance that's what it is
another thing that was important to me
it's family heirloom as a Michael
following your instincts she wasn't
sweet
so with that please join me in thanking
so Michael and ceramic